President Biden made a stunning
admission about the migrant crisis at
our Southern border Fox News
correspondent Lucas thomsson is in rovi
Beach Delaware with the president
tonight Lucas Joey President Biden isn't
ready to call the situation on the
southern border a crisis but he did
admit to our own Jackie Heinrich the
border is not secure and do you believe
that that the border is secure sir no
it's not I haven't reled it for the last
10 years and I've said it for the last
10 years do you believe your give me the
money do you believe your policies have
enabled any of this crisis in the border
that you're ring with now I ask for
thousand everything
judges Biden is not on the ballot in the
upcoming New Hampshire primary on
Tuesday someone to write in his name he
will also be competing with the word
ceasefire voters in the granite state
say immigration is one of their top
issues Senator Rick Scott just said in
the last hour the president has long
ignored the Border why doesn't Biden
secure the Border he could secure the
Border today if he wanted to do it we
have millions of people coming across
our Southern border unvetted we have no
idea who they are we have drugs
criminals terrorists come across Biden
you have the you have the law right now
that you could do it as a candidate Joe
Biden finished fifth in the New
Hampshire Primary in 2020 just behind
Elizabeth Warren Joey thanks Lucas I
hope uh hope you got your smoothie or
your coffee hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else